vous le voyez le jeune justin trudeau
qui entraient au 24 sussex
avec ses deux frères c'est là qu'il est
né justin trudeau est bien le futur
premier ministre ne remettra pas les
pieds de sitôt un marc godbout à ottawa
finalement la décision était prise après
des années et des années de discussions
on va rénover la maison officielle le 24
sussex
alors les trudeau qui devrait aménager
dans une résidence qui est située pas
très loin du 24 sussex donc sur les
terrains de rideau alcon inc du parti
libéral en début d'après midi qui a
confirmé la nouvelle essentiellement ils
y demeureront jusqu'à nouvel ordre
rideau catch parce que c'est comme ça
c'est celle là qu'on voit la scène 0
voilà donc bâtiment en brique est une
résidence composée de 22 22 pièces qui
se trouvent dans un coin boisé donc
aride orale sur la propriété de rideau
hall on a complété les travaux de
rénovation en 2013 essentiellement dans
cette résidence et je vais vous laisser
la porte parole du gouverneur général la
décrire davantage une résidence qui
était construite en 1867 ça fait partie
des terrains de rideau à arles depuis
c'est triste d'en cela a été la maison
des secrétaires du gouverneur général
qui le principal conseiller du
gouverneur général
donc si une maison de style victorien
un bâtiment qui et qui est protégé
ça va prendre combien de temps les
rénovations 24 sussex où et combien
temps monsieur trudeau habitera donc à
rideau carleton
c'est la question qu'on peut se poser
parce que ce qu'on sait à tout le moins
pour l'instant c'est que ça pourrait
prendre au moins deux ans au niveau des
travaux au 24 sussex essentiellement les
fenêtres la crise n'ont pas été
remplacés là-bas depuis quoi les années
50 ce sont les fenêtres dans le fond
original la plupart en tous cas presque
tout don doit être rénové à l'intérieur
la ccn qui est la commission de la
capitale nationale qui gère les
résidences officielles est bien temps de
faire des travaux majeurs là-bas depuis
depuis des années pour ne pas dire des
décennies elle n'a jamais été capable de
pouvoir les désamorcer essentiellement
parce que les premiers ministres ont
toujours refusé de quitter le 24 sussex
pour la simple et bonne raison ou
d'entreprendre si vous voulez de grands
chantiers dans cette résidence là pour
la simple et bonne raison qu'il ya un
problème
craignant dans le fond la perception du
public de sorte que les derniers travaux
d'envergure remonte à il y a près de 60
ans ben voila merci ben ali auront lieu
les travaux merci maman pouvoir